la rider Cup se jouera au Golf National
à 5qutin en yvelin en 2018 compétition
qui oppose par équipe les meilleurs
américains aux meilleurs européens ça va
fédérer plusieurs milliers de personnes
sur place 80000 personnes sont attendues
par jour et surtout plus d'un milliard
de téléspectateurs puisque bien
évidemment l'événement est diffusé à
travers le monde entier bonsoir Joë
Lenan vous êtes Le Président d'une toute
nouvelle association Sky golf 2018
association qui va promouvoir
populariser le golf à sa-quentin en
Eveline d'ici le grand rendez-vous 2018
c'est loin et pourtant déjà
l'association est prête et bien c'est
loin c'est vrai 2018 mais il faut savoir
que l'organisation Laer Cup demande que
tout soit prêt et en place pour 2016
déjà donc c'est déjà le temps est un peu
plus court et puis promouvoir le golf en
France on sait que c'est un travail de
longue Aline n sommes pas un pays
anglo-saxon autant le golf av répandu
aux États-Unis en Angleterre il a très
peu de de culture
il y il y a très peu de culture golfique
même si
aujourd'hui la Fédération Française de
Golf voit un nombre d'adhérence
multiplié de façon importante tous les
ans donc c'est un sport qui progresse
très très fortement comment vous allez
vous y prendre pour populariser le golf
à 50 neline dans les prochains
mois il y a plusieurs manifestations
possibles on y réfléchit aujourd'hui
l'association s'est créé on a lancé le
20 novembre officiellement cette
association on a pour vous donner une
idée on a organisé un un golf nocturne
il y avait 300 personnes quand même on a
récupéré si je puis dire une centaine
d'adhérents à cette occasion là donc ça
c'est le premier événement et ensuite on
va à partir du printemps on a
l'intention de faire découverte du golf
et pratique du golf pour les élus de
Saint-Quentin parce qu'on pense que le
le relais des élus est important au sein
de leur communes il faut qu'il puissent
promouvoir cette manifestation au
combien importante pour la ville
nouvelle et puis ensuite on sera amené
avant l'Open de France à faire la
découverte du golf dans avec des
manifestations de type street golf
c'està-dire golf dans la rue dans les
centres commerciaux ça sera d'ici au
mois de juin donc ça ce sera d'ici au
mois de juin et puis à l'entrée tout de
suite à la semaine avant avant l'Open de
France on aura des manifestations
d'importance il aura un partenariat
aussi avec les les écoles le but
c'estamener aussi les les jeunes c'est
absolument alors il faut savoir qu'il y
a déjà des manifestations qui existent
puisque il y a des jeunes qui qui
découvre le golf par des associations
diverses et variées et qui sont soutenu
par la Communauté d'Agglomération mais
là on va s'orienter vers une promotion
du golf avec l'Académie de Versailles
c'est-à-dire qu'on va on va essayer
enfin on est en cours de discussion avec
l'Académie pour que le golf soit un
support de de réflexion d'action on peut
imaginer que le golf soit un exemple
dans en cours de mathématique ou encore
découvert de la nature et cetera enfin
que des programmes scolaires à
développés autour du du golf Le Golf
quie tout même une image assez élitiste
malgré tout ça aussi ce sera difficile
pour vous de de passer outre
alorsz à partir du moment où on on
prépare une manifestation celle que vous
citiez tout à l'heure où on va voir dans
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes tous les jours sur le plateau
de SaintQuentin officiellement la
Fédération attend jusqu'à 80000
personnes par jour ça sera encore mieux
que les précédentes éditions où ça situ
en général autour de 60000 à peu près ah
ou oui c'est c'est c'est très conséquent
évidemment qu'aujourd'hui personne ne se
rend compte de ce qui nous attend si je
peux dire mais il va il faut vraiment
préarer les les infrastructures qui vont
bien et évidemment ça va être un un
support primordial pour développer le
golf mais c'est c'est sûr on voit bien
la la la la jeunesse aujourd'hui et en
particulier dans les les facultés les
grandes écoles et cetera la pratique du
golf devient bien bien plus propante
qu'avant tout simplement parce que les
jeunes voyagent et que beaucoup de
jeunes qui qui suivent des des études
vont dans les pays anglo-saxons et
découvrent que la pratique du golf est
quelque chose d'extrêmement répandu et
puis là on parle bien évidemment de la
promotion du golf et puis en 2018 lors
du rendez-vous bien évidemment il y aura
d'autres événements pour accompagner
tout ça du côté de saquanttin en Yveline
on évoque aussi la création de d'unun
d'un grand espace avec tous les
mobilhomes pour accueillir sur plus de
250000 M Carr l'ensemble des mobilomes
pour héberger la la population qui
viendra suivre sur place ses rendez-vous
on parle aussi par exemple de de billets
qui permettrait d'accéder à la
manifestation et puis aussi de visiter
le château de Versailles enfin il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de choses on en
parlera bien évidemment ces prochains
mois et puis tout au long de ces années
qui nous séparent de cet événement
aujourd'hui pour conclure sur cette
association combien de membres vous avez
aujourd'hui on a une centaine de membres
et vous disez combien de membres le but
c'est que tous les CIN qutinois il ad
non peut-être pas mais en tout cas tous
les passionnés de golf aujourd'hui il y
a 1500 adhérents euh au sein de la
Fédération Française de Golf pour la
ville nouvelle on espère doubler tout
simplement Joel lenant un dernier mot on
va changer de thématique thématique avec
vous ça concerne la politique vous êtes
élu aussi forcément sur 50 an neline
conseiller municipal d'opposition à
voisin de Bretonneux sur la liste
ensemble pour voisin on parlait tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs lors de la cérémonie
des vœux de voisin le bretonne sur ce
plateau avec le compte-rendu de de
Catherine zulato en ce qui vous concerne
vous pensez déjà aux élections
municipales de 2014
écoutez évidemment que l'opposition dans
son ensemble y réfléchit je pense que
c'est aussi vrai pour notre opposition
enensem voisins que pour l'opposition de
de Jean de voisin solide
quand on est dans l'opposition et qu'on
a uvré pendant des des années dans
l'opposition c'est évidemment pour venir
proposer un un projet qui est pas
forcément en phase avec le projet du ma
en place donc bien entendu qu'on qu'on y
réfléchit et qu'on et vous pourriez être
candidat vous pourriez être tête de
liste en 2014 c'est prématuré c'est
c'est pas parce que le maire de voisin a
annoncé dès dès les vœux qu'il était
partant qu'il repartait avec son équipe
en tête de liste que il faut pour
longtemps qu'on se précipite on est en
train de réfléchir il y a des il y a des
véléités c'est chez les uns chez les
autres on a des jeunes qui veulent
s'impliquer est-ce qu'il faut pas sans
doute peut-être passer le relais et
préparer l'avenir avec une nouvelle
génération tout ça c'est en en gestation
mais bien évidemment nous viendrons avec
des propositions très concrète vous
serez sur une des listes en tout cas
tête de liste ou non vous serez partant
sur C municipale je serai évidemment
partant mais dans quelles conditions
quelle
po alliance de l'ensemble de
l'opposition en discussion oui
aujourd'hui vous savez que je suis
secrétaire départemental pour le Parti
radical pour les Yvelines Jean-Louis
borlot a été très clair là-dessus pour
lui il faut que des nouveaux talents
sortent et pour que des talents sortent
il faut créer des listes il faut les
soutenir les les supporter les amener en
en position des des d'être élu donc on
va s'y employer voilà merci Joel le nom
d'être venu sur le plateau nous parler
des municipales mais bien évidemment en
priorité de la rider Cup même si ça se
déroule en 2018 les municipales auront
déjà lieu avant mais l'objet de ce soir
c'était la rider Cup et vous pourrez
d'ailleursevoir cette édition cet
entretien en replay sur notre site
internet dès demain mercredi matin je
vous retrouve à 18h mercredi soir en
direct avec de nouveaux invités
notamment Alain Degois le fondateur de
Déclic Théâtre la compagnie d'un pro et
il vient de sortir son premier ouvrage
madeine trap très bonne
soirée
I